Let's talk about your four pillars for a
second.
When I was reading that description,
to me,
what came immediately to mind was a
young child that kind of the epitome of
mindfulness.
You know,
someone who has wisdom of a sort who has
wonder for sure,
who's very giving.
Because we now have a lot of research
that shows that children are naturally
very altruistic.
It seems like a child is kind of the,
the most mindful person you can have and
you even quote the child is father to
the man.
You quote that poem in your book.
So I was wondering if you kind of,
if,
if you agree with that,
if you think that we should be looking
more to kind of prolong our childhood in
a certain way.
Science,
I love the idea of prolonging our
childhood.
Why making it conscious?
Cause if that's the difference,
right?
Is the fact that it's like returning to
the garden of Eden but with
consciousness,
it's a dsl yet by him about,
you know,
returning home but seeing it for the
first time.
One of the things that I,
I often use as,
um,
as a sort of example of how I want to
react to life that has to do with
genuine is the way children get angry,
upset.
They cry.
That's right.
Tamper Tantrum.
And then two minutes later it's gone.
And it's like a different human being.
And I think if we can be like that,
it would be just an amazing way to
experience life instead of holding on to
resentments and Angus and judgments for
yes.
And that affecting a whole experience of
life.
Do you think we need to go to kind of to
that extreme in order to be able to
appreciate mindfulness and incorporate
it,
we need to kind of experience the,
not necessarily burnout a severe as you
did,
but all of the negative things first or
is it possible to just sail on through?
Oh,
I think absolutely.
We can incorporate mindfulness from a
very early age and now increasingly we
see people,
I mean young children being taught to
meditate in order to have,
it's like a tool that they can use at
any point in their lives.
My two daughters made a date and they
encourage each other.
They text each other when one is about
to meditate,
to encourage the other to remember to
do,
how many days.
So they're using it as a tool because
even the most blessed at life is going
to include problems,
challenges,
tragedies,
often.
So if we have a tool that allows us to
return to that centered place,
we all have every religion mentioned
Zaid every philosopher,
you know,
asking me this call date,
give me a place to stand and I can move
the world.
So that place on which we can stand and
deal with whatever life brings us up to
me.
He's just
an incredible adventure to learn to go
back to that place and we don't do it
again and again until we can have easier
access to it.
Yeah.